welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question
yes in the show that gives you too much
information about how
many jedi younglings had to die so that
the cutest one of them could live on to
generate billions for the disney
corporation
i'm eric boss and talking dead jedi with
me today
is off-screen producer zach cuddleston
and i might be wrong but i think this
is your birthday or the day before one
of the two
this is this is my birthday that is
thank you and you got just what i wanted
and then some really in-depth star wars
talk that was the present
happy birthday [ __ ] so glad we
get to celebrate with you today
by working thanks eric and speaking of
work
but be remiss if i didn't make you do a
little bit right now i'm going to ask
you today's big question
hit me with it who saved grogu from the
jedi temple during order 66.
ah yes this big question i believe the
mandalorian season finale
is coming up this friday if you're
watching it after that and they answer
it just
pretend like we are right i don't know
or maybe they didn't answer it hey it's
the big question from this whole season
of the mandalorian remind you guys
chapter 13
we learned from ahsoka tano that grogu
that is his name
is false no way was raised in the jedi
temple on coruscant
many masters trained him she said and as
order 66 went out
someone saved grogu from the jedi temple
and took him
into hiding now we've started to dig
into this question
in other videos on the channel but it
really deserves its own
in-depth deep dive because there are a
lot of
options to consider so i think i'd start
zach with playing
a bit of a guess who does he wear
glasses
people in star wars apparently wear
glasses i think we just learned that dr
pershing might be one of the first star
wars characters on screen to wear
glasses
a whole underrepresented group of people
that star wars has been neglecting four
eyes there's been
more literal four eyes on star wars than
figurative ones
only in the pod racer community is eye
protection really valued
but good on them for actually wearing
their goggles because those steam
punkers just use them for decorative
reasons
say goodbye ratatouille oh
okay so the first thing that we're going
to eliminate some options are whoever
this mystery savior was must have been
alive during order 66 a day but we have
to mention it no luke skywalkers no
qui-gons in there okay
second one that you can flip your tiles
down for zach is
the savior must have been a jedi master
not just any jedi because ahsoka said
that grogu was trained at the jedi
temple but she did not know that
information until she communed with the
child
which is worth noting because grogu is
anakin's age only five years older than
ahsoka making her in the child
contemporaries
she would have been at least aware of
this kid at the temple
so that means that while grogu was at
the temple he must have been
secretly hidden somewhere with only a
few jedi masters knowing about his very
existence
wow so there were levels to the temple
so to speak and there's maybe a secret
more hardcore level
the final level you find out that xenu
created all yes
yeah well then the level above that you
have to fight yourself right like that's
how it works
that's right and then uh risk your life
every two years to be in a mission
impossible
um also the third thing that we can
eliminate this jedi master must have
been
obviously in or near the jedi temple at
the time of order 66
just because the jedi were caught
completely off guard by surprise by
order 66
anyone not within that vicinity would
have really had
very little slash no time to rush to
wherever grogu was in the temple
to save him in escape they are a bunch
of idiots who allow themselves to be
scattered all over the galaxy and not
protect
their crucial home flag and lastly this
i think
zack you and i will enjoy as the fourth
and most critical
reason why we're able to narrow things
down really this is a special ingredient
of new rockstar's theory making the fact
that we
are also screenwriters working in the
film industry with lots of experience
with this stuff
these movies and shows tend to navigate
certain known formulas and tropes
and just because something is
canonically possible according to
nerds commenting on reddit doesn't mean
it is cinematically
plausible today
the walt disney corporation is a
business they want to make money and
reach certain creative goals
so which reveal delivers the greatest
fan service and sets up the star wars
universe
and their overall creative goals it's
not pleasing
or cinematically or thematically fun
just have it be a dude named doug
right we've never seen it before and
we'll never see again
right yeah i got the kid and then the
credits roll and that's it no yeah yeah
they
they want to try to like make us happy
but not make us too pissed off
and they want it to open doors not close
them applying all those guess whose we
got nine faces left
up on our guess who board so i'm gonna
rank these
nine from what i think to be the least
likely to the most likely
so we'll start at number nine who was in
the jedi temple at the time of order 66
anakin skywalker at this point his name
was vader he was the first in the temple
he knew what he was about to do he led
the 500 first to massacre the jedi
even the younglings ah [ __ ]
no god damn it yeah we remember that
scene
and the reason i bring him up is yes he
was there he might have even found the
kid
but zack the fact that anakin himself
slaughtered those kids
makes it unlikely that he would come
across one that looks like master yoda
and be like
i'll keep this one yeah it's the old bad
joke you're dead you're dead you're dead
you're cool
definitely not furthermore it's unlikely
anakin even knew grosgu existed because
remember the jedi council deliberately
refused to make anakin a jedi master
despite palpatine's trying to go around
them and let anakin sit in on the
council meetings
may sweden was like yeah you're still
not one of us shut up take a seat
young skywalker it was uh
only masters it seems like who knew
about grogu according to ahsoka
anakin would not have known and i
actually
think it might be true that grogu might
have been the big reason why anakin was
not allowed on the council
as a master may be out of fear that
anakin's and grogu's matching birth
years made them a daiad and that freaked
out mace windu
can you just briefly explain or remind
us what
what the dyad means in this context eric
yeah yeah it's kind of an extension of
the rule of two from the sith right this
is something that became known to us in
the rise of skywalker
rey and kylo ren were revealed to be
part of a dyad
they're basically two uh beings force
sensitive that are
linked in the force and that the force
is always going to bring them
back together and they are more powerful
together
you don't have to actually be born the
same year kylo ren
and rey were not born the same year but
just kind of like at their existence
uh some point in their lives the force
decides these two are going to be linked
i'd rather not do this now
yeah me too kind of four soul mates if
you will
and as uh for soul mates they have
unique abilities like they have the
ability to force heal
most other jedi do not have the ability
to force seal which has brought up
in a lot of people's minds the fact that
grogu can force heal that he might be
part of a dyad
by extension all right so anakin not
very likely possible just not likely
another option who i might think might
be a bit more likely but still not so
palpatine the chancellor about to be the
emperor
so palpatine was also in the jedi temple
after anakin's massacre they saw that on
the uh security video right
he's like well done my boy now on to
everyone else in the clone wars but uh
he was not a jedi master
we know that he did not have full access
to everything the jedi were thinking
because he needed anakin to spy on the
council for him maybe he was just using
anakin that was just a point to move
anakin closer to him i don't think he
fully knew everything the jedi council
was planning and doing otherwise he
would have destroyed them way earlier
so therefore i think he was also unaware
of grogu's existence
now he was a super powerful sith lord he
might have sensed grogu's presence but
applying his common sense to this think
about it if palpatine were able to get
his hands on grogo then
we would not have had all this drama
over imperial forces trying to get him
now
palpatine's cloning scientists would
have drained that kid of everything
and it killed him and then you know they
probably would add a huge advantage in
the galactic civil war
and mob gideon would be off running some
bureaucracy
he'd be running a kinkos somewhere
definitely he reeks of middle management
to me he'd be using the dark saber to
to slice the you know papers yeah
that's what they do at cake goes that's
that's the only reason i go to cakes i'm
like i need a slicer and they're like
are gonna do anything else here i'm like
i'll buy those swedish fish oh they got
the best swedish for those that can't go
they do they do it's the one place you
can for sure always find
some swedish fish is that a king cups
all right let's move on to a
much more likely option that has come up
and i love that this
jedi keeps coming back up number seven
jocasta new so you remember jocasta knew
she was the elderly librarian of the
jedi temple archive someone who sassed
obi-wan back in attack of the clones
if an item does not appear in our
records it does not exist ooh
frosty frosty um now
she did held the rank of master which is
interesting
so she might have been in the know and a
lot of people are saying because she's
an elderly woman she might be
like a good caretaker of a child you
know i'm not i don't
go for that line of thinking she's just
a jedi master who was there at the time
well again why would she be a good
caretaker of that child and not all the
other children that got killed
right i guess right maybe he's a more
valuable child
this one's at the top of your list and
then uh george lucas's son jedi who
talked to her in the library that day
sees that list she's like why am i not
honest and she's like no reason
now a lot of people shoot down jocasta
new because anakin
killed jocasta new during order 66. so
uh jocasta
might have had some time to hide grogoo
somewhere else
maybe entrust his care to someone else
doug um
but she herself did not escape the
temple
to be able to look after grosgu for
years to come there's some potential for
like a cow
l put him in the escape pod and shoot
him off kind of a thing right
possible possible and we know yoda did
have one of those little odds
that just seemed that species size
that's how he got away from kashyyyk
so maybe in one of those and then
someone else picked them up on the other
side and the
people at kinko's are like okay cool
we'll take care of this hey are you just
using the slicer the reason why jocasta
is not higher on this list zach
is that her case is also hurt by the
fact that luke
later found her personal archives and as
far as we know
there was no mention of grosgu in those
records now maybe there was maybe we'll
find out and
uh that'll cover an episode of the
mandalorian or some spin-off or
something like that some way that luke's
timeline could cross over with grogus
but as of right now jocasta does not
have a role in that so i'm going to move
on to another
a quick option that i kind of lump in
with joe costa but she's more of a
question mark is sir junda asir is a
jedi that calcus crosses paths with in
jedi fallen order
now during order 66 sears said that she
tried to help some young liens escape
which
seems like oh maybe one of those young
loons was groku now
it is not clear that she was on
coruscant at the time actually her
surroundings in that flashback cut scene
uh looked kind of like older ruins and
she was not the rank of jedi master
so i kind of lump her roughly in the
same boat as
jocasta possible not likely next up zach
is
a long shot our man maul
love this so uh here's the deal with
maul
he's alive obviously clone wars season
seven showed his
escape from the clone troopers from
ahsoka's group
she let him escape and this was minutes
after order
66 went out and he knew what was
happening it might make sense for him to
go check out things
uh the jedi temple on coruscant maybe
surveyed that massacre
after vader insidious left there's a lot
there in the jedi temple archives that
would be very
valuable to maul he could have gone
there that night after anakin was gone
and then maybe discovered grogu before
yoda and obi-wan arrived the next
morning
i love this too because again you talked
about fan service
we know dave filoni is a big fan of them
all right put him right
all over his animated uh shows and he
came back in
solo in live action clearly lucasfilm
has a future for
maul in this period of time that's after
order 66 but before we catch back up
with him in the timeline in rebels when
he
reconfronts obi-wan and dies on tatooine
so there's some story left to be told
with this guy
and i just bring up maul because he is a
completely
rogue actor he is not loyal to the
empire the empire betrayed him sidious
betrayed him
he would have no reason to harm or kill
the child or even to pass them
on to the empire if he found them or to
pass them on to the jedi so it would
make sense why grogu is no longer in the
jedi's hands
and maul really is his own actor
controlling his own destiny at this
point he has connections with his
crimson dawn crime network that could be
how grogu ended up in the hands of that
nikto gang
that grogu was in on arvala 7 in the
mandalorian pilot especially
maul sees this thing that's clearly a
valued asset maybe he's in the extra
padded golden emerald chamber at the
temple and he's like ah this little guy
must be worth a lot right he's like oh
this is going to help me in the future
i can sell this or trade this or
something right he's running down the
dorm hallway there's one little hobbit
door where he's like
hmm why is there no name card on this
one
and then he kicks it open and grogue's
in there
not now he's like come on so another
similar
long shot option that a lot of people
are considering that i would say is a
bit more likely than maul
is mace windu now mace windu has been
assumed to be dead
because not many people could survive
that fall out
the chancellor's window but we did not
see a body
mace window might top a lot of fans
lists of someone they want to see come
back
and with the popularity of samoa jackson
and how much disney loves him
to give him this fury show on disney
plus we could see another mace windu
series
in the works now we also know that when
it comes to falling down
those coruscant skyscrapers with all
those fifth element traffic
a lot of the jedi have been able to
survive those falls they just grab on to
a certain taxi and they're like i'm okay
now
i mean swedish still got one working arm
he could have survived that
and he would have been in a unique
position to
know what anakin and what palpatine were
planning to do
he would have had just enough time to
make it back to rush back to
the jedi temple he would have known
about grogu's existence as like the
number
two on the jedi council but what i'll
say about mace windu is it presents a
sad
truth about when mace windu one arm
severed
into a stump limping through the jedi
temple
other young ladies are like mr winty
what is going on
he's like out of my way kid nothing
leave me alone he's only got one arm to
hold one kid
right he's good it's like there's no
room on the left kids
what about this bassinet i got one
priority okay we're moving on to our top
three of my favorite options uh number
three
is yoda so yoda obviously head of the
jedi council he returned to the jedi
temple from kashyyyk
hours after the massacre with obi-wan
surveyed the scene and they were
seemingly undisturbed they seemingly had
like hours to just walk through that
crime scene
without any other clone troopers or
imperial forces being like hey another
jedi
you know they had it on lockdown no
particular rush now if grosgu was kept
in a secret part of the temple
their little hobbit dorm door uh that
only yoda knew about yoda could have
recovered the child from wherever that
was
during this period and it just occurred
after the scene transitions away in
revenge of the sith
yoda obviously the same species as grogu
and was most likely one of the jedi
masters who trained him in the temple if
anybody knew
it would have been yoda would have been
mace windu right but yoda being the one
to save grogu zach wouldn't you say it
seems a little on the nose
like oh well yeah that's what i assumed
that there was a connection with yoda
and grogu why did you keep that a secret
yes it also i mean this show does seem a
little
overly concerned with us not calling
grogu baby yoda
right they insist on telling of the
child and then they give him a real name
so we'll do that
yeah most of the world still kind of
refers to his baby yoda putting him
in contact with the actual yoda seems
like it would only perpetuate the baby
yoda
trend right exactly and i don't think
they want to do that you're exactly
right so that's why i think our next
option is slightly more likely
number two obi-wan kenobi so yeah
obi-wan was with yoda when they returned
to the temple they had it on a lockdown
and yeah he was on the jedi council he
was a jedi master at this point
so as one of the masters he might have
been one of the masters to train baby
yoda especially when one considers that
we have
a whole kenobi series in development one
that will take place between revenge of
the sith and 19 bby
and ob wants death and zero bby right
before the whole battle of yavin
and this could be a great way to
introduce this whole obi-wan series and
explain grogu's early years
but i also feel a little does this help
lucasfilm because think about it
would they want this kenobi series to
just be another star wars disney plus
series about an adult caretaker to
grosgu just set 20 years earlier yeah it
does seem like one of the great gifts of
this series is its independence
right like i mean obviously there's
connections
now with boba fett right tons of
connections to the original trilogy and
everything but
it doesn't have to have all the tie-ins
that kind of weighed down the most
recent film trilogy
it does seem like they would want to
build their series universe
with that kind of freedom to not have to
have constant overlaps right
agreed and that's why i think and i'm
going to get some heat for this
but i think the number one likeliest
jedi master
to have saved baby yoda is seattle hold
on hold on
yaddle was a jedi master on the jedi
council during phantom menace but she
mysteriously stepped down after the
naboo crisis
she of course is the same species as
yoda and grogu and
other times when i've brought up yaddle
in the past i get a lot of these smug
commenters who are like
oh is someone going to tell this guy
that yaddle was already dead before
order 66.
you clever clever people
class you guys are referring to a
legends
story expanded universe not canon in
which seattle yes does die sacrificing
herself to save anakin and an entire
planet it's a cool story she uses her
force to absorb this kind of
deadly toxic gas into it's like a virus
she absorbs it all into her body instead
of letting it disperse into that
planet's atmosphere
but that story is not considered canon
anymore i'm sorry it's not maybe it
should be
maybe think it should be but yaddle
keeps coming back and other things that
are considered canon so yaddle
reappeared in a graphic novel as a
ghostly vision that was fighting
vader she was the last one to die in
that vision
it was just in his mind he was fighting
off these these presences these
projections of jedi and she was also
mentioned
last year in jedi fallen order as having
possibly survived the purge
it honestly seems like the current team
at lucasfilm is deliberately
wanting to leave yaddles fate a blank
page
so that they can write something else on
it and yeah unlike yoda yoda's the most
famous one yaddle isn't a character
casual fans of star wars really know
about but she is kind of one of these
mysterious things that
why did she leave the jedi council after
the phantom menace event
if not to look after something like
grogu
i i love this theory it's also like the
perfect move
that they would make to like send
everybody scrambling to the internet
to be like who is this character and why
should i know that we're like
it's a known character that's shown up
before and yet yeah like you said the
casual fan
not that familiar with the laura of
yaddle and again
maybe they're just gonna decide that
they're never gonna bring her back up
again and that
was the end of the story and they're
gonna decide that the story was canon
but it seems like the move was that that
is not considered canon
she might still be alive that's just
where things are right now
i know it's confusing in the world of
canon and star wars what is and is not
considered
actually true to this world right now
the people currently working on it dave
filoni
pablo hidalgo all these artists all
these genius storytellers are saying
just hold off on this one
we got something coming about yeah if
not why would they bring it up in jedi
fallen order that came out the same
week as grogu into our world in november
2019. why would they have this
weird yeah mention a jedi fallen order
within days
of us figuring out that there is a baby
yoda now now do you think
an addendum to this do you think we'll
find out anything
else about the connection between yaddle
and grogu
i.e could there be a familial
relationship there right it is something
she bore
maybe uh i kind of like the idea that
yoda species does not produce sexually
that they produce
asexually i know we're gonna say if
there are males and there are females
why in all of biological science do we
have male and female things if they
don't mate and produce sexually
i think it could be something else that
like maybe there is a broad spectrum of
sexuality within the yoda species
and that they gestate asexually from
some kind of weird organic process that
is
not necessarily like she carried him in
a womb i think based off what we know
their biology they're most likely to be
egg-based mono-tree mammals you know and
there's a history of like some species
of amphibians that can like change
gender to be able to reproduce if
there's no uh
of the other partner around so yeah who
knows there's all kinds of potential
there i plus i mean
do any of us want to have to answer the
question does yeah
already answered my friend so that's
where we're going to leave it for right
now
if and i know it's a big if if yaddle is
still alive she is
absolutely the most likely option to
have saved grosgu
absolutely but i know it's an if and in
fact i think it
grogu could be a good answer to why she
retired from the jedi council but
if seattle did die and she is not at all
going to be tied in with
the story of grogu then number two i
think obi-wan is the likeliest savior
for this character so that's where we'll
leave it for now we are going to answer
a bite-sized question but first you want
to thank some friends who helped us make
this episode starting with our friends
at
coors light these days everything is go
go go hustle and bustle
and it's kind of a lot and you need a
moment to turn off for a little bit
that's where our sponsor coors light
comes in handy
when i need to really just turn off and
let the day float away i put on a
classic sitcom
i grab a bowl of something tasty and a
nice coarse light
nothing eases a tired mind like some
julie louis dreyfus and cold lagered
beverage they've got some great new
packaging hitting the shelves the new
design features clear skies that invite
you to
sit back unwind drink it all in and the
iconic coors light
mountains still turn blue when your beer
is as cold as the rockies
brand new look same ice cold refreshment
that is why coors light is the one i
choose when i need a moment of chill
so when you want to reset reach for the
beard that's made to chill you can have
coors light delivered by going to
get.coorslight.com and finding local
delivery options near you
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company golden colorado
we also want to thank our friends at
purple mattress for sponsoring this
video sure most mattresses
look the same with sheets on them same
goes for pillows but peel away the
exterior and you'll see they aren't all
created equal those insides are what
makes every purple pillow and mattress
unlike
anything you've ever slept on they have
this cutting edge technology called the
purple grid
it's a pattern comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape and sleep cycle then they have all
of these air channels designed to
neutralize body heat and keep you cool
the same tech in their mattresses is
also in purple pillows
they're engineered for head and neck
support and airflow and i can attest to
that since i've got a purple harmony
pillow myself it's super soft and oh so
nice to my sleepy little head it's not a
little head it's a big head
it keeps me sleeping like a cool and
comfortable baby
you can try every purple product
risk-free with free shipping and returns
and purple has financing available as
low as 0
apr for qualified customers experience
the purple grid and you will sleep like
never before
go to purple.com big question 10
and use the promo code big question 10
for a limited time you will get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
big question 10 promo code big question
10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more terms apply
okay now comes the time for a bite-sized
question that zach and i are gonna
chew up for ya and then spit into your
mouth like you're a baby bird
our question this week comes from our
friend uh mezzo jd
on discord asking now this is a familiar
question that's come up before
if thanos wanted to kill half of the
universe because of resources not being
enough
why didn't thanos just use the infinity
stones to make sure there would be more
and enough resources space etc
it's a great question not only for
philosophical purposes but
because this has been answered by the
filmmakers at least to some degree
this came up in the filmmaker commentary
on the infinity war blu-ray
during the scene in which thanos
explains his history and motives doctor
strange on titan
actually eric do you mind if you and i
just kind of dramatically reenact
the um filmmaker comments oh of course
you be um both russo brothers
and okay if you could do slightly
distinct accents for each of them for
sure
i think that would help the viewer a lot
and then i'm just going to be stephen
mcfeely
yeah christopher marcus was there but he
didn't weigh in on this yeah he was um
pouring everybody coffee we all know
he's the
he's the lowest on the tote of bowling
oh i don't know anything we'll talk
about that okay so
anthony russo says people have asked us
why thanos didn't just use the stones to
double the resources in the universe and
uh clearly
he is not interested and then stephen
mcfeely encounters
no it's about free will okay that
doesn't solve the problem
we're just going to get there millions
of years from now this is an opportunity
for people to get it right you trust
them you know and then joe russo comes
in and says
oh well he was told
no to an idea that he had
that he felt was uh the only solution
and then was uh proved right to himself
when that solution was not acted upon
so his messianic complex
he is now committed to following through
on the
idea that he had many many years ago
he is not a stable although he appears
stable
at times he is not a stable individual
i mean this is like you just pulled off
uh mark ruffalo in that hbo mini series
level
you know like you're playing two
brothers say one actor
two brothers i mean or the winklevoss uh
yeah you just did a wiggle boss on the
social network
a wink of a wiggle box
all the love in the world to these russo
brothers don't get me wrong but they are
some of the wealthiest and most elite
most powerful
filmmakers in the industry i think they
can take this
and we're not calling them dumb we're
just slightly making fun of their speech
patterns which is fine
okay but not not how they said it but
what was said there right what does this
mean
so you you can kind of hear the russo's
truck get up to thanos
basically being a homicidal maniac with
a god complex right who was
kind of aggrieved because he was ignored
for years and years and now the universe
needs a drastic move to be shaken out of
its pattern the overpopulation and over
consumption right
he's an eco-terrorist basically in their
eyes right and terrorist plans aren't
logical right it's not about math
they're it's about drama it's it's big
actions
right get in the headlines yeah mad
scientist goes berserk and we don't have
pictures
yes right it's it's impact over logic
but stephen mcfeely in there right who
wait if you listen to a lot of these
commentaries he's often like
sounds like the smartest guy in the room
when it comes to like character
motivation
he's really sharp but he's clearly put a
lot of thought into this and he makes an
interesting comment
he says that for thanos this is an
opportunity
for people to get it right and that he
trusts them
which is so interesting right that's not
eco-terrorism he's saying
thanos sees there's a lesson to be
learned that he wants to impart
on all of living life or whatever yeah
right i really like that because like
mcfeely acknowledges
the logical problem of simply doubling
space
or resources available to the universe
because
yeah like living beings would just
eventually consume it all
it's like you know if you ever get an
afternoon off and so you just kind of
like slack on your work
like you know you will find a way to
expand whatever you have to do to fill
as much time as you have to do it yeah
exactly
yeah we're all amorphous gases that are
just filling to occupy the space of our
container it's the same as if you had
twice as much food or twice as much
oxygen or
potable water and like the solution
of you know thanos has magical rocks
that can let him do whatever he wants
so like why didn't he just you know ask
the genie to grant him
n plus one resources for every living
being forever
is a little too convenient even in a
movie where magic rocks let you
kill half of all living life right and
it's not that's not cinematic or fun in
any way it's kind of right
yeah i guess you could say the rule is
you get a one-time shot it's not like an
ongoing
application of things on the world you
know it's one blast of radiation that
can do one thing at one time
no substitutions exchanges a refund the
actual act of the snap
isn't a natural force right this crazy
like cosmic magic almost wipes
everything out
but before and after it like the
universe behaves
under like its normal laws right and
that would be altering the laws of the
universe to like be
weirdly perpetuating resources or
something like that so anyways mcfeely
suggests
that thanos wants the universe to be so
traumatized
right so scarred by the tragedy of the
snap but then
on the other side of it they're so
educated by the benefit
of the less populated worlds they might
better control their own population
growth
going forward right he wants to create a
universe full of thanos thinkers
talk about a god complex right he not
only wants everybody to be punished
because of him
but he wants them to become more like
him right he wants to rebuild the
universe in his own image
right and he's giving them free will
which if you're a you know a fan of the
judeo-christian god
is a big core tenant of his uh beliefs
right judeo christian god allows us to
make our own mistakes and to exert
free will right he doesn't control
everything we do smite me
oh mighty smiter speaking of this kind
of
thanos thinkers we kind of saw the
effects of that in endgame
right cap acknowledged the bright side
of the blip
right oh there's whales back in the
hudson right that's right
and i mean to be honest tony and pepper
look like they're living their best life
off in the farm i mean you could argue
they might be happier
than when pre-blip they were you know
industrialists in the city
yeah isn't it interesting that both tony
and thanos became farmers in these years
that's how they decided to live their
retirement years it's almost like
growing
and cooking your own food is like the
best way to reduce your carbon footprint
and be self-sustaining
except uh nobody in north america would
have bananas think about that no mangoes
no pineapples
okay you're just making your free trade
propaganda really pissed i wasn't in the
what was thanos cooking episode
of this i'd love to do more cooking
episodes
please let's get in let's let's do some
butter beer recipes whatever okay
yeah that's just to say right in in the
little snippet of life we got in end
game
post blip we saw that like society was
moving on they were adapting they were
learning
to live in this half of existence
world so it's like they almost did kind
of learn the lesson
in responsibility that thanos wanted
them to learn which is fascinating right
if it wasn't for these pesky kids
these damn avengers right unbearing this
thing
then this might have been right and i'd
have done it too if you kids hadn't come
along i just want to sum it up with like
dennis's thinking is is a little bit
like give a man twice as many fish
he'll eat too many fish but teach half
as many men how to fish
they'll appreciate how quiet it is on
the water
i love that jack that is brilliant that
is so true though
that's exactly how it is us fatties will
gobble up all those fish until there's
no fish left
one could argue just to throw in another
like real world parallel here i think
we've talked about this before
but like agricultural science has
advanced by leaps and bounds especially
in the last 100 years right we now
as a globe right produce way more food
logarithmically more food per acre per
country everything
than we did 100 years ago right and
that's why this like
you know malthus was the guy that
preached that you know the world was
going to be overpopulated and malthusian
economics is like
eventually we're all going to starve
because there'll be more people than we
can feed
sir most of his beliefs have been
roundly kind of defeated
because like he didn't anticipate how
much more efficient agriculture would
get
now maybe that's also led to like food
is cheap now we under appreciate it and
we produce too much of it maybe we eat
too much of it
you know there's all kinds of tendrils
of arguments that branch off of yeah but
um yeah thanos did nothing wrong i did
also like that we got to the bottom
of this quartet of filmmakers who are
basically
the brain trust of marvel phase three
the
eminem and r and r you know because
yeah if you do listen carefully you can
tell that of the two filmmakers joe
russo is really the one who's calling
the shots
and obviously anthony russo plays a role
too it probably helps his brother
think through his thoughts all writing
partners and creative partners have an
inner kind of workings that is essential
to them but then
marcus and mcfeely are fascinating
because i think mcfeely
is the guy who like clearly understands
character motivation and through lines
like he understands
uh cap's thematic journey from that
first film through end game whereas
marcus seems like the guy who
understands like the comics mythology
and how
that applies to it and clearly all four
of these guys and the way they work
together
is why these films are so great and
multifaceted and they've got the great
set pieces and they've got the great
characters right and the story arcs and
the like
they've got everything because those
four guys are bringing so many things
and then who knows what kind of magical
fairy does kevin feige and the other
head honchos and marvel are also
sprinkling on top of it right that fairy
dust was just time travel
uh if he's like make time travel work in
avengers 4 and they're like god damn it
i don't want to do that but all right
and they did a pretty good job they did
a pretty good job good job to them they
deserve
every penny that they're paid for all
their projects those guys had a tall
order and figured it out all right zach
we have time for one final box of scraps
question so our question this week
sticking on this idea of who's saved who
there
have you ever saved someone or have you
ever been saved by someone oh do you
have a good answer for this eric
i don't i'm hoping you go first well
i maybe i've lived a term life i don't
think i've ever been in incredible
mortal danger
nor have i lived a super heroic life
where i've been
snatching people from the the jaws of
death but i will say a moment that
stands out to me you and i both grew up
in north florida
you a little bit more um metropolitan
north florida the jacksonville air
jacksonville yeah i was a little
i was in a rural area columbia county
like city florida what's up
right on the georgia border and like a
lot of my town
you know my friends or like sometimes my
jobs would be kind of spread out
so there's a lot of like country road
driving right where it's like
the forest goes right up to the side of
the road there's kind of trees
right there there's not a lot of median
or anything there maybe there's a ditch
because it's florida in a two or four
lane highway
where you go pretty fast because there's
no traffic and i have a very distinct
memory
this is around 1999. i've just recently
started driving
my first job was as a paper delivery guy
like office paper like the big boxes of
office
like copy paper and i'm driving to the
town next to mine live oak
and um you know just middle of the day
again
mostly open country road i'm i'm hauling
ass in my
1997 nissan hardbody whoa boy that
little
that little truck i get it okay this
time i got some
did you just make a kid rock noise i did
make a kid rock
well i think it's sabotage yes
but but no [ __ ] mama
this is pre-podcast if they jump forward
15 years there would definitely be
this american live blaster on the radio
but at the time it was probably
beastie boys rage against the machine or
something like that and so i'm cruising
probably speeding
and again like the forest comes pretty
close to the road
out of the trees just ahead of me
comes like a gigantic deer like big
rack of horns like you know they count
deer by like the number of points on
their horns because like the the more
points the bigger and the older the deer
is and this was at least like a 10 or 12
point this is a huge deer right
and like they are you know their head
and their rack of horns
is probably four or five feet off the
ground right like
maybe taller than a than a human and
this deer
is coming full speed out of the forest
directly towards the road in front of me
and like
you know this is this is in a moment a
snap right i don't even have time to
like hit the brakes
this deer is gonna run right in front of
me and with that giant rack of horns and
this you know probably like
four or five hundred pound animal it's
gonna hit the front of my car maybe come
crashing through my windshield you know
people die
hitting moose or like out on country
roads all the time
and and like you know i see my life past
before my little 16 year old
eyes and then right at the edge of the
road this tent point this giant
magnificent buck
pauses and i pass and then he runs out
in front of the semi truck that was
behind me
and like and and you know i'm sure poor
poor deer certainly died but the semi
truck which has like a giant grill
right it's not flying through the
windshield you know it hit the front of
the truck i saw the
truck kind of pull over you know
whatever nobody was hurt no big damage
but like the difference between jumping
in front of me and jumping in front of
that truck
was like either way that deer was
probably gonna die but it could have
been life or death for me
so the only thing i've ever been saved
by is some random you know bambi's dad
in the late 90s i think
i love that that is a terrifying very
floridian story for sure
because we've seen every horror film has
featured a deer running in front of the
car and then it
you know it's such a perfect jump scare
yeah see i like to think i've gone
through life blissfully i
assume there are all kinds of um angels
and people
jumping in front of bullets to save me
as i'm just kind of like
and then like i'm like olaf in that one
song um
i am also a snowman who can't stay in
the sun for too long
but uh i've already told a story either
to you or tommy or phillip where i
there was a girl who was fighting with
her boyfriend and i drove her
to the train station and i got out of
the car ready to fight this man
uh but then i was more afraid of her and
i almost stabbed her to death in my car
being out of fear of her
um because i thought it was part of a
scam but no no uh the story i will tell
this time
is uh so zach and i went to university
of florida
and on uh game day weekends things get
crazy especially if it's a rivalry team
or it's another team
in the southeastern conference usually
the first
big nasty rivalry game on the calendar
is
the tennessee game the florida tennessee
game florida and tennessee
for whatever reason hate each other zach
might be able to speak more to that
hatred than i again
i don't know why well we were both like
really good teams from the 90s
we would always beat them and they have
a really big kind of loud boisterous fan
base too
so i lived in the dorm that was closest
to
the stadium on campus and on the friday
night before the game i was walking back
probably from some improv rehearsal
because that's all i did
was just improv rehearsals or improv
shows i was out with some friends and
then i
walked back to my dorm and there is a uh
kid on the ground not moving face
swollen barefoot it's the worst
uh beat up i've ever seen someone he
also seemed out of it might have been
drunk i'm not really sure
and there was some other kid who was
standing over him who's just like i
think he's dead
and i looked at him and the kid kind of
like turned his head and i'm like okay
he's not dead he's not dead
and i'm like we have to call the cops
right and this other kid's like yeah but
i was the first to find him and
i'm worried they're gonna think i did it
and i'm like well i'll just call i'll
just call and then we we called the
police
and uh they got there pretty quick but
this kid
looked like he was about to die and uh
he was wearing a florida sweatshirt
looked like he was out because right
near the stadium you'll remember in
gainesville
across university avenue there's a bunch
of really crappy bars
there's like balls grog house yes
these are places that like every uh
college town has one of these
where it's like oh five cent beers or
something like
that we don't think they don't card
or decorating just come in and get silly
drunk yeah
yeah it's aggressive aggressively
dangerous
but i'm sure this kid was at one of
those probably talked some [ __ ] to some
uh tennessee boys who were in town and
they beat the [ __ ] out of him and left
him
basically for dead the shoeless
detail is so like vivid and
insane now he might have been already
shoeless this is florida
it's not as big a deal to punch somebody
out of their flip-flops than it is to
punch somebody out of their sneakers
right
but uh yeah he did survive the cops
called me the next day chester follow-up
just to get my name and everything
anywho well that is it for this episode
of big question another
very happy birthday to off-screen
producers thank you eric
every every birthday get to spend uh
remotely with you is
is a gifted to itself thanks buddy and
likewise likewise well thank you to zach
for joining me this episode you can
follow zach
at z huddleston on twitter uh you can
follow me at eavos
on instagram and twitter follow new
rockstars on all social send us your big
questions using the hashtag bigquestion
and subscribe to this podcast feed give
us a nice rating review if you don't
mind
of course always subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell we'll see you next
week
uh for a very special holiday episode of
big question
bye everyone
[Music]
you